[Music]
you're such a big sports fan this is a
big sports town are you going up Cubs
game while you're here he was supposed
to go today I didn't get to go I should
my plane came in late I wish I did did
the Cubs win I know yeah all right
Detroit's good so whatever Yankee fan I
know you guys don't like the Yankees but
you're a Yankee fan yeah that's alright
it's alright you guys can live with day
but a ride 23 Grand Slams it's the
record he hit it the other day and I hit
him in that Lou Gary I have the record
most ran slams and I was sitting I heard
this information I was very rabid cuz I
know for a fact I ate 24 Grand Slam
breakfasts you got screwed
yeah that's not right a Conan I shot a
movie I shot that's my boy in
Massachusetts in Conan's in my downtown
I remember this yeah when you were
shooting a movie my cell phone rings and
it's you and your buddy I'm in your
hometown that's right and then I see the
movie and I recognize it's a church
that's right up the road literally like
a hundred hundred yards from my ass
where my parents still live I know I go
there and talk to them that town is the
greatest everybody loves going in there
because he's like the king of the town
he went every I could walk down the
street yeah yeah I'm here hilarious she
not as good as told him all the facts
like there was one kid in particular who
wanted me to say hello he was like hey
he tell Cohen and I said hi I said sure
buddy
what's your name English he won't
remember but he's the guy he gave me a
and I kept pain
I don't know if you can trade hell no
what is his correctly fingers will
remember anyway she says what's up
that's the worst thing you've ever done
oh I'll kill that guy now you know I
first of all I called you the day
because I got to see the movie it's
really funny this is a hilarious movie
and I sincerely enjoyed this film but it
is it's dirty this is a dirty dirty
movie yes is your mom okay with it
no your mom and she's very sweet woman
does she not like it when you when it
gets a little I actually we had to have
a private premiere for my mother I just
rent out of theater and I showed her
Madagascar and I was like there it is
[Laughter]
you didn't curse we didn't curse we
weren't allowed to curse no it was like
a big deal and like truck drivers
everyone everyone in the whole house we
couldn't say sucks we were getting
trouble for socks don't say sucks Thanks
if you want to say stink of Ruby you can
say that and fart fart was not a fart
was like a hostile word in my house yeah
you couldn't say fart you pack yeah till
you made the books my grandmother she
would call it the crap alert and you get
away with that well you know why because
my grandmother unfortunately didn't have
any legs so it was really a big deal
what a heartwarming story a family tale
like you Adam